look even the voice of reason of this
show okay you're the reason a lot of
people haven't thrown something at the
television what for you has the most
challenging part about kind of getting
into this group specifically
um for me what's hard is that if we're
going to be friends
we should trust one another and that's
what's hard you know because how can I
truly be your friend if I can't trust
you so that being said I just hope the
Divide goes away you know if we all come
back
um I hope the Divide between the four
originals and me and Crystal and Sutton
goes away I hope we can all just figure
it out yeah because speaking from an
audience member there's an obvious in
our Circle or whatever you want to call
it what for you was the most difficult
part of the season to watch that
um for sure my birthday party my
birthday party
um my son Oliver is old enough obviously
and
that's fine but it was the Jacks of it
all because it was one thing to know she
said it
and I had an idea of how she said it but
it was another thing to watch it and
then also see the scene
where it was laughed about I would never
do that yeah I would never do that to
someone else and that was really hurtful
how did it feel in that moment to see
Crystal really back up with Jack that
was great that was great she put her
arms around him and that was really
really cool awesome
um how does it feel to be at Bravo Con
in the midst of a review it's got to be
a little weird it's got to be weird and
I haven't seen anybody other than Sutton
um
it's weird because there were things we
didn't end on a resolution this time we
didn't take we didn't say goodbye we
didn't do a cast photo we just all went
our separate ways so it'll be
interesting thank you so much